what up space fam goes in here from
anime All Pro and today we're going to
be going over the final chapter of Demon
Slayer in detail so make sure to stay
tuned for that if you enjoyed these
demon center videos and want to keep
them coming make sure to smash that like
button share this video if you haven't
be sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future Demon Slayer videos for
early access to all of our content
including Demon Slayer you can follow
our podcast anime opera audio on Spotify
Apple podcast or wherever else you
listen to podcasts links in the
description and I'm also sharing any
updates we get about Demon Slayer on our
Instagram at anime up drawer keep in
mind there will be manga spoilers here
I'm talking about the latest and final
chapter chapter 205 after all now
without further ado let's jump into it
if you'll remember from last chapter we
were told that a lot of time has passed
and we are now in the modern age we got
a modern landscape and everything in
this chapter is taking place in that
modern age we start in a bedroom with
two characters who clearly appear to be
descendants of tundra and cano
so as someone who's been shipping those
two since the butterfly estate days I
couldn't be happier right now con
atacama doe who definitely looks like
canals descendant is trying to wake up
his little brother konatess 16 so he's
older than tundra was in demon slayer
tundra was 15 so it's interesting to
compare how peaceful this
sixteen-year-old guy's life has probably
been compared to his great-grandpa
tangelos who had to save the world from
the demon king of pop as a team his
little bro is called su meheeco a nod to
his and chondros ancestors suma yoshi
who was the one who met your ichi and
passed on his breath of the sun' style
in the form of the dance of the fire-god
kinda that tries to wake up his little
bro 28 times but the 15 year old brother
who looks exactly like tundra both with
shorter hair and no demons their mark is
out cold he's pretty much talking to
sleep saying he's awake but he doesn't
even open his eyes clearly kanata is the
mature brother here
you gotta love swimming he goes baby
chicken blanket as well then we see a
full-page color spread of the new
generation this chapter is called a
light that shines through time we see
the descendants of all of our main
characters we see the two brothers weave
and kanata whose hair is expertly
covered by a Sakura flower in this image
is holding the hand of Natsu Cole's
descendant and then we seize any tooth
black hair descendant remember that situ
initially had black hair - before the
lightening tree incident at first it
seemed weird that the Natsuko looking
girl was not with designer - looking boy
but that makes sense since we discover
that the two are siblings which means
that my boys and it's who did in fact
married as Yuko amazing and at first it
might seem a bit weird that tons of
descendant seems to be dating their
Zuko's descendant but keep in mind they
share like the same great-great
grandparents so it's pretty removed
finally we have the enou scale looking
dude in the back not part of the group
unfortunately but he's here nonetheless
I mean yes a part of me wishes he was
part of the main group but what can you
do I think it's enough that both are
Tundra X canal and sunny 2x Natsuko
ships worked out we are told in his
modern-day Tokyo and we jumped to AG
Asuma Yoshi taro does I need to look in
descendant this is a hilarious part
where the 17 year old Yoshi taro is
readings I need to his journal and what
happened against Musa even calling him
the demon boss I love it this is like me
reacting to the manga he reads about how
everybody worked together to defeat the
demon king of pop and he really gets
into it tears in his eyes and everything
then his musical looking sister kicks
your sheet arrow in the back letting us
know that Zen is who was their great
grandfather and that most people think
that zytle account is fictional rather
than authentic and it definitely would
be hard to believe that all those things
happened in modern times so this is a
nice little moment hinting at how we
perhaps tend to downplay the
accomplishments and stories of our
ancestors here top quahog Asuma is
actually the oldest at 18 years old
while nez Zuko was the youngest the age
stuff is going to play a fun role as we
move on here
Yoshi taro is just like his great
Grandpa's I need soo he cries
energetically telling her that it's all
true and that they all thought amazingly
in risked their lives
toko flips it on him and says if they
were so brave why can't you she Ted who
even study and do well rather than
embarrassing himself in school after all
he failed his exams last time and that
also really reminds me of us weebs
reading epic manga getting lost in these
life and death
amazing stories and then having to do
something like studying which can seem
pretty mundane compared to slaying the
demon king toko can clearly be
aggressive and actually lectures her
little bro she pulls his ear yoshi petal
points out that all of the woman in his
family are well behaved
meaning nice and nonviolent nazgûl was
super nice for example but the violent
aspect was a bit foreshadowed when desi
Co said she'd hit ton judo if he didn't
stop apologizing and feeling bad for
what he's done as a demon it's an
interesting choice now that we have
someone who looks exactly like her cute
precious Natsuko but is also not so nice
and can be violent to Yoshi Tara then
brings up the idea of reincarnation a
recurring idea in the series and the
idea that makes this chapter the perfect
way to finish off Demon Slayer Yoshi
taro says that he's sure all the people
who passed away fighting that demons
have been reborn in our living happy
lives and we definitely see this at work
in this chapter we are led to believe
that these familiar looking characters
that we'll see in this chapter are the
reincarnations of those characters we
knew in the past for instance we see
Tenma Zoe who obviously is related to
and has the same energy as tengan Azula
in this world since he can't fight
demons be a ninja or occupy all his time
with his three wives
he's a cool athlete he's 20 and he
flamboyantly mocks the reporter as he
holds up his gold medal in gymnastics
while yoshi tare who thinks that woozi
has a bad personality since he's mocking
the reporter instead of accepting the
medal humbly taco is quick to come to
his defense since she's clearly a fan of
the dreamy athlete she believes that the
reporter must have provoked easily and
that's why he's acting that way then in
a very zen eat away your [ __ ] tato
mentions how handsome guys can get away
with anything and after all they don't
have those I got to my eyebrows to worry
about that's when we see eNOS case
clearly shy descendant as with eNOS gay
he has a girly face and Yoshi taro
assumes that he's a beautiful girl at
first hoshi birra is a botanist and he
was working with the legendary blue
spider lily a loose end that a lot of
fans were wondering about the rare Lily
comes out for only two or three days and
blooms only during the day making it
practically impossible for Mouzon to
find in the dark hoshi betta was
studying this rare blue spider lily but
accidentally let them wither away we see
as any 2s double standard here at its
most hilarious at first year she Tarot
wonders how anyone could attack such a
beautiful woman for something like that
and comments on how the world is an
awful place
when toca lets her low brother know that
hashiba
is in fact a man Yoshi Ted who quickly
switches his tune and wants the man to
die for making such a stupid mistake
toko lets us know that their dad and
likely most men in the family are like
Zetas too and had that double standard
when it comes to beautiful woman you
know the Sanji syndrome we see muy cheer
on his twin reincarnated as babies again
showing how age can fluctuate here even
though muy cheer on des ago we're pretty
much the same age before here they're
look-alikes are almost 18 years apart
these changes in age actually made this
chapter pretty fun and interesting
Yoshi taro sees and admires the beauty
of the reincarnations of Shinobu and
Kenai who are just regular high school
girls here although a lot of people
hated to see so many pillars died it's
nice to know that their spirit didn't
die and they got reincarnate into these
clearly happy lives some people may have
a problem with this but I'm a fan
especially because reincarnation was
brought up before and not something that
came out of nowhere this was likely the
mangakas plan from the beginning then
Coco gets all lovey-dovey around kanata
who complements her hair I love seeing
how cute she behaves here compared to
how dangerous she was with her little
brother they call each other the most
handsome and the cutest and the
girlfriendless Yoshi taro is wondering
how he can curse them just by looking at
that he may be part overprotective of
his sister but he's also probably
jealous just house me2 was always
jealous of other guys who had girls in
the past we see gomes reincarnation and
the gentle giant is a kindergarten
teacher which is absolutely perfect for
him then in one panel we get some of the
happiest news of all if you'll remember
eager OHS whole thing was that he wanted
to die the feeling moves on to atone for
his sins and then he wished he could be
reincarnated and marry meet suti in a
future life and in this panel we see
them together operating a restaurant
this part made me so happy I can't even
describe it in words knowing that after
everything these two got what they
always wished for and got married in
their future
it's just so romantic and satisfying if
for nothing else this part made this
chapter amazing and necessary I don't
care what anyone else says can we please
get a like on this video to celebrate
this amazing
tears of joy where the love story we
then find out that Yoshi taro was
looking at me to these reincarnations
chests and so he grows reincarnation in
usual eternal fashion
got jealous and threw a knife at him
which is absolutely amazing
we jump to Future tundra with short hair
and he finally wakes up he notices he is
late and wondered why no one woke him up
even after caneta tried like 30 times to
wake him up
I gotta admit this is totally me I'll
turn off my alarm when I'm half asleep
and then freak out when I wake up late I
can totally relate sue me he cold pieces
out through the window and he clearly
got some moves passed down to him except
he's using him to get to school and do
parkour instead of to fight bloodthirsty
demons you gotta appreciate his
impressive moves and these kinds of
scenes definitely make me believe that a
Demon Slayer sequel in modern times
would be amazing sue meheeco lets us
know that he wants a perfect attendance
award which caught me off guard for a
guy who sleeps in but hey it is what it
is when I think of someone sleeping in I
think of Shinobu from honey and clover
and that guy practically missed every
single class since he was either
sleeping or making money by the way if
you like romance and slice-of-life I
strongly recommend honey and clover one
of my favorite anime of all time on the
way to school sue me he co sees the
reincarnation of zenit zeus insane who
lets us know that he does this every
morning
the old man says kids these days which
is pretty hilarious since this whole
chapter proves that kids are not that
different now than they were generations
ago although we may have had some
technological breakthroughs over the
years the human condition really hasn't
changed much
I find myself reading books written
2,000 years ago by Roman authors and it
would shock you how similar their lives
were to our own that's why I love art
philosophy and the humanities you can
say that science from 2,000 years ago
is outdated but the human condition our
human desire for love friendship success
and tranquillity has always been
consistent and that's shown clearly in
this chapter we then see that we Isshiki
curse has in fact been broken after
Muslims defeat and not only that
the oldest person in Japan is a boy
ishiki that's hilarious and so nice to
see this chapter literally had me
laughing joyfully throughout with such
moments sooo meheeco keeps going we see
a sign for a maintenance shop named
after the swordsmith hagen azúcar and
then we run into the reincarnation of
the little butterfly state girls then
sue meheeco can't even stop for a cop
car and parcours right over it dude this
guy's got guts and even more so because
the cops are reincarnation of ganya and
sana me and they recognize that sooo
meheeco must be the kid that was
reported seven times already clearly a
consistent troublemaker even though he
seems like a pretty nice guy if a bit
careless we get another funny age
difference while sana me and Kenya are
adult cops geez reincarnation is younger
than soo meheeco and he's with saboteurs
reincarnation and McComas reincarnation
they're all happy enjoying some toys
while GU was usually a downer in the
series because he blamed himself for
losing his best friend sabi toe here he
has a great big smile which is really
nice to see he's clearly no longer
traumatized by that past incident then
we see a Tomeo looking girl on a phone
screen and of course Yoshi Ted who shows
up and knows all about the painting he
tells us that our boy you should know is
still alive as I assumed he would be if
you remember Tundra told him to live on
so he could remember Tommy oh and this
is probably the best way to do that
he keeps remembering her through
paintings and through these paintings
other people can enjoy her beauty as
well it is only recently that his
paintings have been praised worldwide he
is the only non reincarnation here he's
been living his immortal life all this
time and it seems like only non demons
can be reincarnated which is why we
don't see demons who killed people like
Icaza moves on and even Tommy of here it
seems like they go to that other place
and can't be reincarnated you should
know being his usual antisocial self
shot a rifle at a reporter who came to
interview him that's hilarious and
probably keeping a distance from people
is a wise move since if he lets people
get too close they'll eventually figure
out that he's not aging at all even as
he keeps pushing out more and more
paintings over the centuries yoshi taro
clearly an expert lets the boys know
that his first love was
painting number 812 glass flowers and
Tamayo and that gives us a sense of how
many paintings have actually been made I
personally really like how you shoot
Ozark turned out then more amazing news
the dango coup that we love so much is
back reincarnated to be the same age as
Tundras reincarnation
his name is Totoro rather than children
but you can immediately notice their
similarities like that big bright smile
and those very unique eyebrows fittingly
then goku is still as motivated as ever
and he woke up early at 4 a.m. for
sparring and lost track of the time he
tries to get Komodo to join the kendo
team too
the cops come and try to get their
attention but the two kids keep rushing
on to school ignoring that unlike the
committed dango Kusumi hiko doesn't want
to join any sports clubs because it
would cut down on his sleep time you got
to respect his love of sleep and after
everything Tundra went through the last
time he probably deserves to take it
easy this time around then we see
Murata's reincarnation and again he's a
funny side character he's tried to close
the school gate before too late students
make it in but they just jump over the
fence which is hilarious I've seen anime
where the school gates are closing but I
can't remember seeing people actually
just jump over it it's great to see how
much fun these guys are having and then
Goku is just radiating positive vibes as
usual we jump to hashiba who's worried
about getting fired after the blue
spider lily mix-up he says he wants to
live alone in the mountains a nod to
eNOS K's past life in the wild this
hushaby era is being drawn there too
admittedly though hushaby restore II is
my least favorite in this chapter since
I would like to see him be friends with
the others and I do miss eNOS Kay's
personality then presumably the Cobb
brothers have called sue makiko's mother
and she's shocked to hear about her son
and apologizes for the inconvenience
she then looks at some pictures on the
wall I'm guessing painted ones and we
see the survivors celebrating after to
the feet of Musa Zen enthused reaction
is the best as he's blushing with his
head resting against mezu combs pure
happiness and it's a great picture to
wrap up the story along with the
earrings that your ichi passed out to
ton zero and now to the present
Commodore family as readers we are
thanked for read
demon slayer all this time and we're
told to look forward to the mangakas
next work we don't know exactly what the
next work will be about but I'm
definitely gonna check it out no matter
what
what are you Cauchy the mangaka for my
hero academia even wrote to thank Gothel
gay for this amazing manga and called
demon slayer a legend and it really is
it's been amazing experiencing it weekly
with all of you we have the anime movie
and the rest of the seasons to look
forward to a side story about n goku and
perhaps more sequel / spin-offs let me
know what you thought about this final
chapter of demon slayer in the comments
I really did like it a lot because it
brings everything together the people
that lost their lives and suffered
against Musa got rewarded for their
brave efforts and sacrifices with a more
peaceful and happy reincarnation
it's like Karma and the manga has been
hinting at this at the very least since
uro said he wished to be reincarnated
and to marry meet suti in a future life
and we got that like I said I laugh
joyfully a bunch of times throughout
this chapter and I think most fans and
demons there will enjoy this ending
since it is very much in alignment with
the mangaka style
eNOS K's reincarnation is the only thing
I wasn't crazy about but the rest was
amazing and I'm so happy that all the
ships I've been rooting for throughout
actually came to fruition even the fact
that hushaby era was named alba points
to the fact that he knows ke probably
did end up with Aoi in the past another
ship I mentioned last chapter so overall
I love this series and although I
thought the demon king tons of stuff was
a bit rushed
I did love this ending I look forward to
more demon serie anime stuff and stories
and will definitely keep covering this
legendary series on this channel and
that is it for today's review if you
enjoyed this review be sure to smash
that like button and share this video if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial
hit that notification bell because you
will miss future and even Sailor videos
if you don't and remember that you can
get early access to all of our content
including Demon Slayer by following our
anime out / audio podcast
links in the description I'm also
sharing any updates we get about Demon
Slayer sequels spin-offs and the anime
on our Instagram at anime uproar so I
hope to see you there lastly the YouTube
ad rates have significantly dropped
recently so the help and support we're
getting from
anime uproar patrons is now more
important than ever a very special thank
you goes to our patrons over on patreon
who help us survive these YouTube issues
and who helped make videos like this one
possible first and foremost I want to
thank the legend acknowledged by Lord
Twigg Oh himself
Efrain a and the one tier patrons the
ones who stay atop all clans Steven
grata alone autumn the world stealers
Tyson Kirino acquire respect potato
Jonathan King deci deep Brandon of miles
Papa Smurf Emperor otaku and Ritchie
Martinez and our pro hero to your
patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson King cell
just Anatole Kazansky angel Cruz I
Sparky 65 cricket XP Ted no Ted Jo
Stanton very Gucci Alicia actor animal
69 jessica calif on he no commie and
water bonnie parks so dr 12 with doing
they Ora TNF Wong mich loves anime
cynical Kraken and JCC wocka thank you
all so much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon calm
and Mail Pro and becoming a patron today
for as little as $1 if you do so your
gear name featured in future videos
alongside these amazing people right
here and you'll even get access to a
private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course bank
memes so check out patreon.com/lenguin
that way if you prefer which ever way
you choose to support us you can get the
same great benefits thanks again and
until next time see you space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]